[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه
والله
حتى النهايه برئاسيه تركيا واردوغان يؤكد
انه سيحقق فوزا تاريخيا في جوله الح
[موسيقى]
سمين
خدعه غربيه
مع دخول اقتتال السودان شهره الثاني
تحذيرات من انهيار القطاع الصحي والبرهان
يواصل حمله الاقالات
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
رئيس بيلاروسيا يظهر بعض ايام من غياب
اثار شائعات بشان حالاته الصحيه
اهلا بكم نبدا من اخر تطورات الانتخابات
في تركيا اذ قال رئيس رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان في بيان له ان شعبه انجز انتخابات
رئاسه التركيه والتي تعد على حد وصفه
واحده من الانتخابات الاكثر مشاركه في
تاريخ تركيا مشيرا الى ان هذه الانتخابات
تليق بي ديمقراطيه تركيا وقال اردوغان انه
هو رغم تقدمه
باثنين مليون ونصف مليون صوت وبفرق نصف
درجه مئويه ستكون هناك اعاده لجوله
الانتخابات مؤكدا ان الاصوات التي حصل
عليها
ستتضاعف وسيشهد فوزا تاريخيا في جوله
الاعاده
بالمقابل نشر كمال كليتش دور اوغلو مقطع
فيديو على حسابه على تويتر قائلا انه
سيقاتل حتى النهايه على حد وصفه
في السياق اعتبر المرشح الرئاسي سنان ان
تقديمه الدعم لاي طرف في جوله الاعاده
سيمكنه من الفوز برئاسه التركيه مشيرا الى
انه سيعلن خلال يومين عن المرشح الذي
سيدعمه واضاف اوغان ان هناك خطوط حمراء
وشروط لهذا الدعم على راسها مكافحه
الارهاب والابتعاد عن الاحزاب السياسيه
التي تدعمها التنظيمات الارهابيه بالاضافه
الى ترحيل اللاجئين
شروط غوغان لترجيح كفه اردوغان او كليتش
دارولو
حصل على مليونين وثمانمائه
على اردوغان اعاده اللاجئين وبقائهم خط
احمر بالنسبه لنا
دعم كريستيانو مرهون بعدم تقديمه تنازلات
للاكراد
القوميون الاتراك والاتاتوكيون ستكون لهم
كلمه حاسمه في جوله الاعاده
سنتشاور مع قاعده ناخبين قبل التوصل لقرار
حول جوله الاعاده
الينا من اسطنبول المفضل العربيه طاهر
بركه ومن كهرمان مرعش مفرد العربيه غسان
ابو لوز اهلا بكما ابدا معك طاهر يعني ما
هي اهم ردود الفعل الداخليه الرسميه
المعارضه وايضا الشعبيه على نتائج الجوله
الاولى والتوجه الى جوله اعاده
اهلا بك يا راويه وبالمشاهدين ردود الفعل
الشعبيه طيله هذا اليوم رصدناها من خلال
التنقل في المدن المختلفه في المناطق
مختلفه في داخل اسطنبول بين مناطق مؤيده
تعتبر مؤيده لحزب الشعب الجمهوري ومناطق
مؤيده لحزب العداله والتنميه الحماس شديد
جدا ولعله يزيد اكثر فاكثر من الان حتى
جوله الاعاده اما بخصوص
بعض التصريحات الرسميه اضافه الى تلك التي
يعني عرضتيها قبل قليل في بدايه النشره
نشير الى ما قاله احمد داوود اوغلو رئيس
حزب المستقبل والذي تحدث قائلا
اقول باعتبار شخصا فاز بالعديد من
الانتخابات من قبل وخرج بنجاح من عمليات
كان يعتقد انها هزائم لن ينتهي الامر حتى
نقول انتهى الامر وهو منشق عن حزب الع
والتنميه وكان قياديا كبيرا فيه مع الرئيس
اردوغان وانضم الى تحالف الامه
معوجلو اذا ليس هناك اعتراف بانه الامر قد
قضي بنتائج الجوله الاولى رغم الفارق حتى
الان رئيس حزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم علي
بابا جان ايضا المنشق عن حزب العداله
والتنميه والمنضم الى تحالف الامه بزعامه
وهما طبعا من المحافظين يتحدث عن ضروره
جمع المحافظين والليبراليين هذه المره جمع
اليسار واليمين ويقول سندخل كل بيت وكل
شارع حتى الجوله الثانيه لاقناع الناس
بجوله الاعاده بانتخابنا انتخاب مرشحنا
كليتش دار اوغلو الذي يدعمونه ويضيف حان
وقت حسد جميع جهودنا من اجل فوز مرشحنا
كمال كليتش دار اوغلو ولا تنسوا يقول علي
بابا جان لم نهزم عندما نسقط بل عندما
نياس اما على الطرف الاخر فاضافه الى ما
قاله وتفضلتي به الرئيس اردوغان تحدث
المتحدث باسم الحزب العداله والتنميه عمر
تشيليك الذي استمعنا اليه كثيرا بالامس
ايضا قال لقد اضاف رئيسنا اردوغان نجاحا
جديدا بالنتيجه التي حصل عليها والكل تفرج
على العرس الديمقراطي كما سماه متهما
الجانب الاخر خاصه اكرم امام اوغلو ومن
سوريا
بالتجاوز الديمقراطيه عندما اتهموا وكاله
انباء الاناضول ببث ارقام غير صحيحه وقال
المتحدث ايضا لقد اتهموا وكاله الاناضول
لكن في النهايه ظهرت صحه النتائج التي
اعلنت عنها الوكاله طبعا الاتهامات
والتراشق دائما في هذا الموضوع والكلام
دائما عن انه الاناضول في انتخابات 2019
اتهمت بانها اوقفت نشر النتائج لانها لم
تكن في صالحها في انتخابات البلديه التي
خسرها حزب العداله والتنميه في اسطنبول
وانقره كما تذكورين اما وكاله الانباء
المعارضه انكا في انتخابات 2023 فاتهمت من
الطرف الاخر بانها هي التي ابطات ظهور
النتائج وقلبتها في بعض الاوقات اذا هذه
هي يعني حده الاتهامات والشد والجذب
والاخذ والرد بين الطرفين كما سالتي حول
الردود الشعبيه والردود الرسميه كذلك حتى
ساعه راويه نعم انتقل طاهر لنتعرف على وقع
نتائج هذه الانتخابات على انصار الرئيس
التركي الحالي من كهرمان مرعش غسان ماذا
عن ردود الفعل عندك
بالفعل راويه على الاقل هنا في ولايه
كهرمان مرعش هنا الناخبون في ولايه كهرمان
مرعش ينامون مطمئنون بحسب النتائج التي
حققتها لصالح الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
تاريخيا معروف ان هذه الولايه تصوت للرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان وايضا تصوت لحزب العداله
وتنميه وكان متوقعا هذه متوقعا هذه
النتيجه
لصالح اردوغان وبالتالي كان هناك ايضا
مراهنه او المعارضه تحاول اللعب على ورقه
كارثه الزلزال لكن النتائج جاءت غير ذلك
والارقام جاءت غير ذلك نتحدث عن اكثر من
71% حصل عليها اردوغان من هذه الولايه
ليله امس كان ليلى كانت ليله صاخبه جدا
وكانت الاحتفالات تملا شوارع مدينه كهرمان
مرعش وبقيت المواكب تجوب الشوارع وايضا
الحدود الحشود من المناصرين لحزب العداله
والتنميه يجتمعون امام مقر
حزب العداله والتنميه في وسط مدينه كهرمان
مرعش حتى ساعه متاخره من ليله امس وبقوا
يحتفلون في ذلك وعندما سالناهم ان هناك
ممكن ان يكون هناك جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات قالوا لا داعي للقلق ونحن لا
نخشى شيء هذه الارقام تتحدث عن نفسها هناك
اجماع على الرئيس اردوغان وبالتالي سنعيد
التصويت للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في الجوله
المقبله وفي الانتخابات السابقه راويه حصل
حزب العداله والتنميه على سته مقاعد من
هنا من كهرمان مرعش والتي هي نصيبها
ثمانيه مقاعد في البرلمان التركي ايضا حقق
الرئيس اردوغان فوزا يعني كبيرا في 8
ولايات من اصل عشر ولايات متضرره في جنوب
البلاد وهذا يعكس حقيقه حجم سيطره الرئيس
اردوغان وحزب العداله وتنميه على هذه
الولايات رغم كارثه الزلزال التي كما قل
المعارضه كانت طيله الاشهر الماضيه خلال
حملتها الانتخابيه وادعائيه تحاول ان توجد
شرخا بين صفوف الناخبين الموالين للرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان لكن الارقام جاءت عكس ذلك
حتى في ولايه اضنه التي يعني على عاده
تصوت للمعرضه اليوم كانت النتائج متقاربه
جدا بين كلجدار اوغلو والرئيس اردوغان
والرئيس اردوغان وبالتالي هذه الارقام
تعكس يعني مدى سيطره اردوغان وحزب العداله
والتنميه في هذه الولايات رغم الكارثه
ورغم بطء عمليات اعاده الاعمار التي وعد
بها الرئيس اردوغان خلال عام تسليم منازل
للمتضررين خلال عام لكن لكنهم يعني يقولون
بان هذه الكارثه هي كارثه طبيعيه والحكومه
قدمت ما في وسعها واكثر من ذلك وايضا هم
مصممون على دعم الرئيس اردوغان لانه بوجهه
نظرهم صاحب مش قدم الكثير للبلاد خلال
عشرين عاما من حكمه وبالتالي هم يريدون
بقاء اردوغان لاكمال هذا المشروع الذين
يؤمنون به سواء كان الرئيس او بالحزب نعم
اعود الى مفدنا طاهر بركه طاهر يعني يحكي
عن حاله احباط كبيره لدى
المناصري المعارضه من النتيجه التي حققت
وبانه ذلك قد يؤثر على جوله الاعاده وعلى
الاقبال ان لا يكون قياسيا كما في الجوله
الاولى ما الذي لمسته شعبيا بهذه النقطه
تحديدا
راويه ربما هذا يدفعهم اكثر حتى لو كانت
خيبه امل حاليا من النتيجه التي حققها
ولكنها ربما تشحنهم وتشحذ همامهم للفتره
المقبله في الاسبوعين المقبلين كما قلت لك
قبل قليل مثلا ما الذي قاله علي بابا جان
ما الذي قاله احمد داود اوغلو ما الذي
تقوله المعارضه ككل حتى كليتش دار اوبلو
في الفيديو الذي عرضتيه كان محتدا جدا
فيما يتعلق ايضا بمحرم انجي ولو لم يكن
جزءا من تحالف الامه الا انه ايضا تحدث عن
موضوع
ضروره عدم فقدان الامل اذا هناك خيبه امل
حاليا ولكن في الفتره المقبله ربما هذا
يجعلهم يعني يتعنتون اكثر في طرح مرشحهم
التغييري الذي يريدونه ولكن طبعا لعبه
ورعبه التحالفات واي عوامل يمكن ان تظهر
بشكل فجائي لاحظنا قبل ثلاثه ايام من
الجوله الاولى كيف غير انسحاب محرم انجي
من السباق الكثير من معالمه والكثير من
التحالفات وبدانا نسال الى اين ستذهب
الاصوات والى ما هنالك والان نسال اين
ستذهب اصوات سنان اوغان وربما ظهرت
تسريبات جديده او فيديوهات فضائحيه جديده
وكان تم التهديد بها من قبل هل تركت
للجوله الثانيه لمقابل الجوله الثانيه لكي
تكون ضربه قاضيه على اوغلو مثلا مثلا اذا
حصل وكما هدد البعض بنشر تسجيلات للقاءات
له في الولايات المتحده مع جماعه فتح الله
جولين او مع اخرين ربما يعتبروه البعض في
تركيا غير وطني بين قوسين اذا صح التعبير
كما يقول حزب العداله والتنميه ربما تكون
ضربه قاضيه او يحصل العكس يعني ربما تظهر
مفاجات جديده يعني تجعل ارقامه ترتفع
مجددا
بحكم تحالفات جديده بحكم واقع جديد في
خلال اسبوعين ولكن الارقام في الجوله
الاولى وقصر المده باسبوعين فقط قد لا
يعدان بالكثير شكرا جزيلا لك طاهر بركه
وغسان ابو لوز واعطيكم الف عافيه انتم
وباقي الزملاء شكرا جزيلا
ابرز التحالفات الانتخابيه بالبرلمان
التركي
تحالف الجمهور
322 مقعدا تتوزع على حزب العداله والتنميه
ب 267 مقعدا حزب الحركه القوميه 50 مقعدا
حزب الرفاه الجديد خمسه مقاعد
الاتحاد الكبير بدون مقاعد
تحالف الامه 213 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب الشعب الجمهوري ب 169 مقعدا
حزب الجيد باربعه واربعين مقعدا
تحالف العمل والحريه 65 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب اليسار الاخضر بواحد وستين
مقعدا وحزب العمال باربعه مقاعد
التباين سمه التنافس الانتخابي وهذه نظره
على ابرز الاختلافات بين مرشحي الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
نبدا مع وعود حمله رجب طيب اردوغان ومنها
صياغه دستور مدني جديده وتحقيق الاستقرار
السياسي والاقتصادي اقتصاديا يعد اردوغان
برفع الحد الادنى للاجور وزياده رواتب
المتقاعدين وتخفيض البطاله الى اقل من 5%
وابقاء التضخم في خانه الاحد من الوعود
الداخليه ايضا زياده فرص العمل واعطاء
تسهيلات نقديه للمواطنين وزياده القدره
الشرائيه لهم داخليا ايضا يسعى اردوغان
الى الاسراع بالعوده الطوعيه لمليون سوري
من خلال اتفاق مع الرئيس بشار الاسد وبشكل
موازن سيعمل الرئيس التركي حسب تصريحاته
على على الكفاءات من السوريين خاصه
الاطباء والمهندسين الذين حصل كثير منهم
على الجنسيه التركيه معتبرا طردهم عملا
غير انساني خارجيا وثق الرئيس التركي
علاقاته علاقات بلاده مع الصين وروسيا
ودعى لان تتبنى تركيا تحالفات متعدده
الاطراف ننتقل الى الضفه الاخرى ضفه
المعارضه ووعود لتشدار اوغلو اولويه
المعارضه داخليا هي اعاده نظام الحكم
الرئاسي الحالي الى النظام البرلماني
واستعاده منصب رئيس الوزراء اقتصاديا وعد
كمال كليتشدار اوغلو بخفض التضخم عبر
اتباع السياسات الاقتصاديه التقليديه
واعاده الاستقلال للبنك المركزي ايضا من
وعود المعارضه توفير فرص العمل ومكافحه
الغلاء وجذب رؤوس الاموال العالميه اما
فيما يتعلق بملف اللاجئين السوريين فتدعم
المعارضه اعاده العلاقات مع سوريا لتوفير
بيئه امنه تشجع لعودتهم اضافه للوعد
باتمام عمليه الاعاده خلال عامين اما
خارجيا فاعلنت المعارضه ان اولويتها هي
عوده المفاوضات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي حول
انضمام تركيا للتكتل كذلك تسعى المعارضه
لتوجيه العلاقات نحو الغرب مره اخرى بما
في ذلك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واعاده
تركيا الى برنامج طائرات الاف 35 المقاتله
التي استبعدت منه تركيا بعد شرائها دفاعات
صاروخيه روسيه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي التركي فراس
اوغلو فراس رضوان اوغلو اذن اهلا بك سيد
فراس طبعا التباينات بين اردوغان وكليتش
دور اوغلو ان كان بالفكر وان كان بالوعود
الانتخابيه والمشاريع واضحه
ومن سيحسم الجوله الثانيه برايك
هو سؤال يعني ليس يعني سهلا ولكن وفق
المعطيات التي حصلت في النتائج الاخيره
ويعني وفقه عمليه رياضيه ورقميه
اليس اللغه ربما اقرب حقيقه
للفوز ربما في الجوله الثانيه هو يحتاج
الى نصف نقطه فقط
وطبعا في حال كلا الطرفين استطاع ان يحتفظ
بكل من صوت لهما اي الكتله التصويتيه التي
جاءت لهما
والفارق بين طرفين كبير يعني سيد كمال
يحتاج الى اكثر من تقريبا ست نقاط يعني
يحتاج الى اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين صوت
ورئيس اردوغان يحتاج الى نفس نصف نقطه
يعني بين 4500,000 صوت هذا يعني اظن يعطي
الاولويه اكثر الى الرئيس اردوغان اضافه
الى ان ربما
كتله التي سبقت للسيد سنان ربما تميل اكثر
الى مصالحها وهي ستتوافق مع الرابح الاكثر
وهو الرئيس اردوغان وهو الموجود الان في
الكفه الرابحه يعني انا اظن يعني هناك
صعوبه للسيد كمال لكن يعني كل شيء واريد
استبعد الحقيقه
فوز السيد كمال لانه يحتاج الى اكثر من
ثلاثه ملايين صوت على الاقل مما يخص
البرلمان والتوزيع الجديد كيف سيؤثر ذلك
برايك على المشهد السياسي خاصه بانه
شاهدنا فوزا او انتصارا كبيرا هكذا يوصف
للقوميين صعود كبير لهم
نعم يعني الصعود لحزب الحركه القوميه اكثر
من المره الماضيه تراجع للحزب للحزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي او اليسار والخضر او
التكتل العمل والحريه كان لديهم اظن 70
نائما في
المرحله السابقه الان هم في 65 ربما نائبا
هذا تراجع هو ذا تراجع ضجه لصالح
الائتلاف الحاكم سواء لتحديدا ربما اكثر
لعداله والتنميه لان لديه ايضا انصار من
الاحزاب الكرديه الاسلاميه لكن في نفس
الوقت لم ينجح في
لنقل في استقطاب ولايات كان نجح فيها في
المره السابقه اربع ولايات كان اخذها من
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الان لم ينجح في
هذا لكن في المجمل الائتلاف الحاكم اوتلاف
الجمهور لديه الان الزياده البرلمانيه
يعني لديهم 300 زائد الان لديهم 321 اظن
نائبا
حققوا الاغلبيه نوع في البرلمان التركي
هناك نقطه مهمه جدا اظن هو تراجع اذا
ذكرنا الى الاعداد التي صوتت لكلا الطرفين
في اسطنبول وانقر تحديدا سنجد ان كلا
المدينتين الاصوات الاكثر
ذهبت للمعارضه ليس بالكبير ولكن هذا يعني
ان اسطنبول وانقره صوتت للمعارضه
وبالتالي تاثيرات ذلك يعني حتى بالزخم زخم
الجوله الثانيه هل تتوقع ان يكون بنفس
الجوله الاولى خاصه ما يحكى وكنت سالت
زميلنا الطاهر منذ قليل عن يعني ياس
واحباط لدى جمهور المعارضه من النتيجه
التي حصلت وكان هناك توقعات بان يحققوا
نتائج اهم من ذلك هل الان العمل هو على
النقاط والحسابات ام على رفع يعني الروح
المعنويه وروح التغيير من جديد الذي سيكون
اهم تحدي ربما للطاوله السداسيه نحو
جمهورها
ليس لديهم خيار اخر والا
سيحل هذا العقد بينهم بكل احوال الارقام
اللي هي لصالح اردوغان بكل تاكيد
صعب ان نتوقع ان يحصلوا على ارقام زائده
عما حصلوا عليه في المره الماضيه لكن هم
حصلوا على ارقام اكبر مما كانت عليها لنقل
في الانتخابات السابقه وان لم يكن موجود
هناك حزبا لم يكن المؤسسان تاسس بعد
الانتخابات السابقه لكن بالمجمل المعارضه
تزيد عددها ايضا نقطه ثانيه
لابد من هذا الزخم
الزخ الاعلامي للانصار والا ربما لن يذهب
للانتخابات او ربما سيكون لهم الاحباط لان
النخب السياسيه تفكيرها مختلف عن الجماهير
هي تفكر الى اشياء ابعد هل لابد انه
يفكرون باتجاه انتصار في بلديه في
انتخابات البلديه اسطنبول وانقره لابد انه
لابد ان يفكرون
بما يسمى الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
ليست الان القادمه هذه الاحزاب لابد ان
تستمر ولابد ان لديها قاعده جمهوريه كبيره
لديها مشاريعها واحزاب كبيره جدا اظن في
هذا السياق لابد ان تبقي قاعده الجمعيه
التي لديك اضافه الى نحن نتكلم على سته
احزاب متعدده الطوائف السياسيه وحتى
الايدلوجيه ولذلك كل هذه التصريحات اظن
انها مهمه جدا على الاقل ممكن ان تحاول
استعاده الامر في انتخاب في 28 من هذا
الشهر ولكن انا اظن ان لابد الامساك كل ما
يمكن
يعني مسك الخيوط لديهم حتى يبقى هذا
الائتلاف قائبا والا سهل جدا ان ينحل هذا
الائتلاف بينهم شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
الكاتب الصحفي التركي فراس رضوان اوغلو
الاول لاعب كره قدم كان يطمح لاكمال
مسيرته الاحترافيه والثاني موظف حكومي
وكلاهما يتنافسان الان على رئاسه تركيا
رجب طيب اردوغان وكليتش دار اوغلو كل بدا
حياته بعيدا عن السياسه
لتسوق مها
تاتي بهم الاقدار للتنافس على الوصول الى
القمه
[موسيقى]
كان ابوه قبطان بحريا لكنه عشق كره القدم
تمتع رجب طيب اردوغان بموهبه كرويه لافته
في الاعداداديه والثانويه لعب لصالح نادي
جامع الرياضي مقابل الف ليره شهريا اطلق
عليه اصدقائه لقب الامام بيكنباور كابورا
ونمت مهاراته وتلقى عروضا من انديه اسكي
وفنربحشي لكن والده عارض الامر
بدات في الرابعه عشر بلعب كره القدم في
الحي كنت وقتها طالبا في المرحله الثانويه
وكنت اتدرب في اكاديميه اسطنبول لكره
القدم ايضا بعد الانتهاء من المدرسه حاولت
دخول كليه التربيه الرياضيه واحتراف كره
القدم لكن والدي رحمه الله اعترض ومنعني
من اجل اكمال الدراسه ولم اتمكن من احتراف
كره القدم
منافسه في الانتخابات كمال كالجدار اوغلو
ولد بمنطقه ريفيه شرق الاناضول لعائله
علويه كان والده موظفا حكوميا فسار على
سير ابيه عمل محاسبا ثم تدرج في الوظائف
الحكوميه الى ان اصبح رئيسا لمؤسسه الضمان
الاجتماعي ساقت الاقدار الرجلين من عالم
الرياضه والوظيفه الى دهاليز السياسه حتى
المنافسه على رئاسه تركيا
ومع ذلك ما زال اردوغان لا يفوت فرصه الا
واظهر فيها مهاراته الرياضيه كذلك
الذي نشر صوره في المطبخ كموظف عادي يساعد
زوجته في الاعمال المنزليه
[موسيقى]
تابعونا معنا بعد الفاصل
سوناك يستبعد ارسال مقاتلات بريطانيه
لاوكرانيا والسبب تفضيل اكياف مقاتلات اف
16 الامريك
يه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ساخره رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه افرين من تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن
بوست افاد بانه عرض على كياف معلومات حول
مواقع القوات الروسيه ووصف التقرير
بالملحق مرجحا ان يكون افراد من النخبه
الروسيه وراءه اما الكرملين فوصف
المعلومات التي نشرتها واشنطن بالمضلله
العديد من الاسماء تم تدورها في الحرب
الاوكرانيه الدائره ربما ابرزها كان
يفخيني بريجوجين فمن هو هذا الرجل لنعد
اولا الى بداياته ينحدر بيجوجين من مدينه
في السجن بتهم تتعلق بالسرقه والانتماء
الى عصابه مسيرته التجاريه ارتبطت بتسويق
الطعام وايضا المواد الغذائيه قبل ان يؤسس
سلسله متاجر للبقاله ثم انتقل لعلم
المطاعم وفي عام 2014 اسس بريجوجين شركه
فاجنر اول واكبر شركه مرتبطه بالدوله
للمقاولين العسكريين عاد بريكوجين للواجهه
مجددا في حرب اوكرانيا مع دخول قوات فاجنر
على الخط والتي اصبحت محورا اساسيا
للمعارك شرق اوكرانيا ومع احتدام القتال
في بخموت قال مؤسس فاجنر ان الاركان ووزير
الدفاع يصدران الاوامر بشكل عشوائي
ويطلبان عدم تسليم الذخيره لمجموعه فاجنر
في محاوله لتدميرها بريكوجين كان قليل
الظهور سابقا ليصبح اليوم وجه حرب روسيا
ضد اوكرانيا ما اثار تكهنات حول ايذاء وعن
طموح هذا الرجل السياسي تحديدا ومع صمت
الكريم الكبير يرى مراقبون ان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين قادر على السيطره على كافه
الشخصيات وان بامكانه سحب ريوجين من
الواجهه ليعود لتنفيذ مهام سياسيه لكن من
وراء الكواليس ومن موسكو ينضم الينا رائد
جبر
المحلل السياسي ومدير مكتب جريده الشرق
الاوسط في موسكو اهلا بك سيد رائد يعني
عندما تسمع تقرير استخباراتيه يقول بانه
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر بريكوجين قد عرض تزويد
كياف بمعلومات حول مواقع روسيه هل ترى هذا
الاحتمال منطقيا يعني كيف يمكن قراءته
لانه هنا نتحدث عن خيانه
نعم صحيح هذه خيانه اذا ثبتت لكن لا اعتقد
ان هذه المعطيات صحيحه اعتقد انها جزء من
التسريبات التي يعني كما تذكرين كان هناك
حديث عن ان بعض التسريبات تم فبركتها من
اجل تظليل الروس وربما التعامل يعني
بطريقه او يعني تسريب معلومات من اجل
استخدامها في
وقت كون هذه المعلومه واحده من تلك
المسائل علينا ان نتذكر انه الصحيفه
الرصينه
الى ولا يمكن ان تنشر معطيات من دون ان
تكون متاكده منها لذلك يبدو انه
باخر تحريفها ثم تسريبها لاهداف معينه لكن
اللافت الموضوع نفسه يوجه اصابع الاتهام
داخليه هذا امر يعني له اهميه خاصه لانه
يبدو انه هذا التسريب سوف يمنح كلا
الطرفين يعني الذين ظهرت بينهم خلافاتهما
وزاره الدفاع من جانب ومجموعه من جانب
لاستخدام هذه المعطيات كلا حسب يعني
اهوائه وحسب مزاجه من اجل تقديمها الى
الرئيس صاحب القرار الرئيس الذي مربوطين
شخصيا بانه هناك شكوك كبيره تحيط عموما
يعني رد
واضح على سؤالك لا اعتقد انه يمكن ان نذهب
نحو هذه الخطوه لاسباب عديده منها انه هو
مدرج اصلا على اللوائح المطلوبين للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومتهم باداره منظمه
متشدده
ومتطرفه وما الى ذلك
مم
نوعه من السودان
والماس وما الى ذلك لذلك يبدو مستبعدا ان
يذهب ريجوجل نح
و وهو كان الافضل بالنسبه
اليك اذا كان يريد
الدفاع ان يذهب نحو اوساط غربيه وليس الى
اوكرانيا ولكن السيد رائد لماذا يصمت
الكرملين لماذا يعني لا يوقف هذه الحرب
بين بريجوجين وايضا وزير الدفاع ووزير
ورئيس الاركان الرئيس بوتين يعني
علامات استفهام كبيره حول هذه الحرب
الكلاميه بالتصريحات بين الطرفين
صحيح صحيح تماما هذه تساؤلات
محقه وهي منتشره بشكل واسع في روسيا حتى
الان ليس مفهوما الموقف الكريم انه هذا
الاتزان الصمت يعني نحن نذكر هنا انه خلف
ابواب مغلقه كان دعا اكثر من مره الى
اللقاءات على مستوى وزاره الدفاع ومجموعه
من اجل تقريب وجهات النظر لكن ليس مفهوما
لم تحق
قت كبيره لكن ليس مفهوما لماذا
يقف امام هذا التجاذب القوي وانه الاتهام
بالخيانه بين الطرفين وما الى ذلك يعني
كما تذكرين انتاهم وزير الدفاع بالتخاذل
بشكل مباشر واعتبر انه سحب بعض القوات من
اطراف ماتش هو خيانه للشعب الروسي وما الى
ذلك اذا نحن امام اتهامات يعني قويه جدا
لا يبدو مفهوما تماما بسبب صمت لانه ان
كانت هناك
تشير الى انه
يحتاج قوات لانه لديها قوات مداهمه
واقتحام مدربه جيدا وقويه ومسلحه جيدا في
وقت يفتقد الجيش الروسي الذي اعتاد على
التدرب للحرب التقليديه وليس لحروب
الشوارع يفتقد لهذه المهارات لهذه القدرات
هي متوفره لدى قوات الشيشانيه التي تقاتل
ايضا في جنوب اورينا هذه النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه كما تشير بعد التقديراتنا
انه تثبت هذه المجموعه اكتسبت شعبيه واسعه
خلال الشهور الاخيره وحتى بعد هذا ظهر
عندما برز الخلاف مع وزاره الدفاع انه
تقريبا كل الاحزاب السياسيه الروسيه وقفت
الى جانب فاجنر ووجهت نداءات عاجله للرئيس
الروسي بصفته القائد الاعلى للجيش والقوات
المسلحه من اجل يعني تقديم الطلبات التي
ترغب بها او طلبتها في اسرع وقت تسبيح
والذخيره وميل ذلك اذا امام المجموعه امام
مجموعه الشعبيه واسعه ولا يريد يبدو ان
يذهب بعيدا يعني
باختصار لو سمحت انا انتهى وقتي ولكن كان
هناك امس تقرير بصحيفه واشنطن بوست نقلا
عن وثائق البنتاجون المسربه ومفادها
النازلين يريد قصف مناطق روسيه واحتلال
مدن حدوديه وكان هناك حديث سابق لرئيس
مجموعه فاجنر يتحدث بانه اوكرانيا تود
مهاجمه
ماذا ان حصل هذا السيناريو
سيكون خطير جدا لانه سوف يعني حرب مفتوحه
كامله حتى الان موسكو حذرت من انه اي
امدادات للاسلحه يمكن ان تصل الى داخل
الاراضي الروسيه سوف تتعامل معها موسكو
بشكل جدي جدا من خلال يعني ضرب مصادرها
وناقلاتها وميل ذلك هذا يعني انخراط بشكل
او او باخر انخراط مباشر لاطراف في حلف
شمال الاطلسي في هذه الحرب هذا امر خطير
وتطور خطير جدا سيكون لكن هنا اريد
باعجاله ان انبه لانه موسكو تردد دائما
انه حتى الاعتداءات
المناطق التي ضمتها روسيا في خريف العرضي
هو اعتداء على اراضي روسيا الاتحاديه اذا
نحن امام موقف يعني ربما يشكل رساله قويه
الى الكرم لانه ربما يدفع نحو في حال يعني
صارت الامور في هذا السيناريو شكرا جزيلا
لك من موسكو رائد جبر مدير مكتب جريده
الشرق الاوسط في موس
كو استبعد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك وجودا خطط لارسال مقاتلات
لاوكرانيا خصوصا انها تفضل استخدام
مقاتلات افسته عشر الامريكيه واكد سوناك
خلال لقائه مع
بريطانيا ستكون من ضمن تحالف دولي سيدرب
الاوكرانيين على استخدام الطائرات الحربيه
قريبا
قبل ذلك اكدت بريطانيا تزويد اوكرانيا
بصواريخ بعيده المدى وبحسب وزير الدفاع
البريطاني بنوالص فان الصواريخ من نوع
ستورم شادو ستمنح لاوكرانيا افضل فرصه
للدفاع عن نفسها
صواريخه ستورم شادو من نوع جو ارض بعيده
المدى مداها اكثر من 250 كيلومترا مقارنه
بصواريخ هاي مارس التي زودتها بها
الولايات المتحده بمدن لا يتجاوز 80
كيلومترا يتم اطلاق الصواريخ من الطائرات
ما يعني ان الطيارين الاوكرانيين سيكونون
قادرين على البقاء بعيدا عن الخطوط
الاماميه هذا وقد زودت بريطانيا اوكرانيا
مسبقا بمعدات عسكريه اخرى منها اربع عشره
دبابه تشالنجر اثنان في يناير الماضي
وطائرات بدون طيار من نوع مالويتي 150
القادره على التحليق لست وثلاثين دقيقه
ويتم التحكم فيها من قبل جندي عبر حاسوب
قال الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ان
فرنسا منفتحه على تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين المقاتلين في البلاد واضاف
رئيس الفرنسي في مقابله على قناه اف ان
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين يمكن ان يبدا
على الفور لافتا الى انه لا يوجد محرمات
بهذا الشان وكشف ماكرون انه لم يناقش
تسليم طائرات حربيه الى اوكرانيا مع رئيس
الاوكراني وانه ناقش مساله الصواريخ
والتدريب فقط
اكد المندوب الروسي الدائم لدى الامم
المتحده ان العقوبات الغربيه لا تزال تعيق
الامدادات الزراعيه الروسيه دون اي امل في
تخفيفها عن الاسمده والمنتجات الغذائيه
وقال المندوب الروسي في اجتماعا لمجلس
الامن الدولي ان الوضع لم يشهد اي تقدم في
الجزء الخاص بروسيا من صفقه الحبوب منذ
عام واضاف ان البنك الروسي الذي تتركز
اعماله بالتسويه الماليه لعمليات التصدير
الزراعيه لا يزال خاضعا للعقوبات
[موسيقى]
اصدر قائد الجيش السوداني ورئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقاليه عبد الفتاح البرهان
قرارا باعفاء مدير عام الشرطه ووزير
الداخليه المكلف عدنان حامد محمد عمر من
منصبه وانهاء خدمه سفيرين من العمل لوزاره
الخارجيه قرار البرهان هذا جاء ضمن سلسله
اقالات كان اخرها اعفاء محافظ البنك
المركزي امس كما اصدر قرارا بتجميد حسابات
قوات الدعم السريع وشركاتها في جميع
البنوك بالسودان وفروعها في الخارج
وفي التطورات الميدانيه اتهمت قوات الدعم
السريع الجيش السوداني بشان هجمات جويه
على مناطق ماهوله بالمدنيين بالعاصمه
الخرطوم بالاضافه الى استهداف مستشفى شرق
النيله ومن جهتها قالت مصادر مقربه من
الجيش السوداني ان الدعم السريع استخدم
المستشفى
كنقطه عسكريه لتخزين الذخيره وانه لا يوجد
ضحايا مدنيين في الهجوم
ومع دخول الاشتباكات في السودان شهرها
الثاني قالت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
ان المرافق الصحيه في السودان على وشك
الانهيار واضافت ان مرافق الرعايه الصحيه
في السودان تعاني منذ اسابيع من نقص
الامدادات والعلاج مشيره الى توقف اكثر من
70% من المستشفيات عن العمل
ابرز الاحداث في السودان منذ بدء الاقتتال
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع نستعرضها
بالعرض التالي
ابرز احداث النزاع في السودان في الخامس
عشر من ابريل وبعد ايام قليله من تاجيل
جديد لتوقيع اتفاق سياسي بدا النزاع بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في السادس عشر
من الشهر الماضي اعلن برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي تعليق عمله في السودان بعد مقتل
عدد من عمال الاغاثه في دارفور اليومان
الثالث والرابع من النزاع شهدا خرقه
هدنتين معلنتين في الثاني والعشرين من
ابريل اصبحت السعوديه اول دوله تجري
مدنيين من السودان ولحقتها دول اخرى في
الخامس والعشرين من ابريل دخلت حيز
التنفيذ هدنه لثنتين وسبعين ساعه بواسطه
سعوديه وامريكيه تلتها هدن اخرى في نفس
اليوم اعلن احمد هارون وهو احد مساعدي
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير قراره من السجن
رفقه مسؤولين سابقين اخرين في السادس
والعشرين من ابريل اكد الجيش ان البشير
محتجز لدى الشرطه القضائيه
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار لا 72 ساعه اضافيه
في الثامن والعشرين من ابريل لكن القتال
العنيف السمر
محادثات جده بدات في السادس من مايك
برعايه سعوديه وامريكيه وبعد مفاوضات بسته
ايام وقع الجانبان اعلانا يضمن السماح
بمرور امن للمدنيين لمغادره مناطق القتال
ودخول المساعدات الانسانيه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الاردنيه تعرض مبنى
سفارتها في الخرطوم لاقتحام وتخريب وعربت
الخارجيه عن ادانتها واستنكارها للاعتداء
الذي تعرضت له السفاره ولكافه اعمال العنف
والتخريب خاصه تلك التي تستهدف المباني
الدبلوماسيه وتنتهكه سيادتها كما اشارت
الخارجيه الاردنيه الى ان البعثه في
السودان بخير وانها موجوده في مدينه
بورتسودان
استقبل وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان نظيرته الالمانيه انالينا بيربوك
في جده وعربت عن شكري وتقدير بلادها لما
قامت به المملكه من عمليات اجلاء لرعايه
المانيا من السودان منوهه بالكفاءه
العاليه للجهات السعوديه في نجاح هذه
العمليه وعقد الجانبان جلسه مباحثات رسميه
تطرقت لسبل تعزيز جهود البلدين في ارساء
دعائم السلام بالمنطقه والعالم
[موسيقى]
بشكل غير متوقع بايدن يعلق على الانتخابات
التركيه تابعونا بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تونس قناه محكمه
مختصه في قضايا الارهاب بسجن راشد الغنوشي
رئيس حركه النهضه لمده عام وتغريمان ذكرت
المحكمه ان الغنوشي ادينا غيابيا بوصف
الاجهزه الامنيه بالطواغيت الامر الذي
يندرج ضمن افعال مجرمه وفقا للقانون
التونسي واعتبرته تحريضا على استهداف قوه
العمله
[موسيقى]
بعد غياب عن احتفالات رسميه اثار شكوكا
حول حالته الصحيه
ظهر الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو
في مقطع فيديو نشرته الوكاله الرسميه
واظهر الفيديو الرئيس بيلاروسي وهو يتفقد
منشاه للقوات الجويه وكان لوكا شيكو قد
تغيب عن اجتماع حكومي بشان الفساد ولم
يظهر في الاحتفال بيوم العالم يوم الاحد
مما اثار تكهنات بشان حالاته الصحيه ودفع
المعارضه لدعوه الشعب للاستعداد لتغييرات
سياسيه
[موسيقى]
بعد ثلاثه ايام من الاحداث التي وقعت
بالقرب منا اعني في منطقه بريانسك عندما
تم اسقاط اربع طائرات واضطرنا للرد نحن في
حاله تاهب قصوى لذلك انا مهتم بمعرفه
الوضع في جميع انحاء البلاد وبالطبع معرفه
وجهات النظر حول تطورها هذا الوضع
والمثير للجدل بعد انتشار شائعات عن تدهور
صحه لوكاشينكو وتداول انباء عن معاناته من
مرض خطير دعت المعارضه بيلاروسيه في
المنفى الشعبي للاستعداد للتغيير السياسي
بالنسبه لنا هذا يعني شيئا واحدا علينا ان
نتحضر جيدا لاي سيناريو من اجل تحويل
بيلاروسيا لطريق الديمقراطيه ومنع روسيا
من التدخل
[موسيقى]
بدل مادي او حتى التبرع بالمبلغ لاطفال
مصابين بالسرطان مبادره خاصه اطلقها بيار
بعقليمي ولقد استحسان البنك الدولي وعلى
اثرها تمويل مشاريع مماثله لوزاره البيئه
طلبت بالتغيير
بس ما حدا نجاوب ليش بدي ابلش انا انه
طالب بالتغيير ليش ما ببلشوا انا لحالك
لا تنطوا طلوا على الزبائن يقفوا
هي عباره عن مقتنيات يمتلكها الجميع لكن
قله تفكر باستثمارها
اطنان من النفايات يتخلى عنها اللبنانيون
مقابل المال في خضم ازمتهم الاقتصاديه
حينا او يتبرعون بمردودها لاطفال مرضى
السرطان احيانا هكذا ابتكر بيار حلا يرضي
الجميع
وباستثمار مني بسيارتي بلشت استثمرت بوقتي
وبحاله نحن نبغى الربح وعم نربح
ما هي طريقه لحتى نحمي البيئه غير انه كل
شيء وثاني شيء انه طريقه لحتى نقدر نحن
الشباب هم بلبنان شو عم نقدر نطلع كتير
مصاري سوق لحتى نقدر نطلع شوي مصاري زياده
شجع فيها المواطنين على فرز النفايات في
منازلهم وقد فاق عدد الزبائن توقعات
الشركه التي سارعت الى افتتاح فرع سان لها
خلال اشهر كل تعني النفايات عم بيجي لعنا
عم نكون عم نخفف عن الدوله 60 دولار للطمه
هذا اقل ما فينا نقوله نحن بهاي الفرع
لحاله بثلاثه اشهر اكثر من 43 طن تخيلوا
المبلغ اللي قدرنا نوفره على الدوله
بالاضافه للدوره الاقتصاديه اللي خلقناها
منها المواد ومنها التوظيفات قدرنا نعمل
من اسبوع بمتابعه مكثفه مع وزير البيئه
افتتاح لعشر مراكز ضمن بلديه بيروت
بالتعاون مع البنك الدولي بهبها اجت منه
وراح يشرفوا عليها اليو ان دي بي
في معمل متواضع تعالج النفايات حيث تكبس
وتفرم وتعجن قبل ان يعاد بيعها لمصانع
محليه اما الفائض فيصدر الى مصر وتركيا
ودول اوروبيه
مره جديده تثبت المبادرات الخاصه قدرتها
على التفوق على الدوله لاختلاق حلول
لازمات يدفع ثمنها اللبنانيون غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت
[موسيقى]
ليفوز من يفوز هناك ما يكفي من المشاكل في
تلك المنطقه من العالم هذا التصريح للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في تعليقه على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في تركيا وايضا خالف
في تصريحاته العالم الذي تابع عن كثب
مجريات الانتخابات لكنه ربما اراد تبرئه
نفسه من اتهامات وشهاء اليه اردوغان قبل
يوم من التصويت فقد قال اردوغان ان
المعارضه تعمل مع بايدن للاطاحه به دعيا
انصاره للرد على هذه المساعي بالادلاء
بصوتهم بالانتخابات
صوره اليوم من السودان تراه مبتسما وهو
يعيد تعبئه مخزن اسلحه برصاصه فارغه
يخالها لعبه مناسبه للسنه لكنه لا يدرك ان
تلك الرصاصات جزء من لعبه تعود الكبار على
ممارستها لعبه تنتشر في بلاده منذ زمن لكن
الخاسر فيها لا يعود تلك هي لعبه الموتى
الصوره من شمال الخرطوم حيث يدور الاقتتال
بين رفقاء السلاح الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه
قد تظن انها مشاهد من فيلم سينمائي يتحدث
عن حلبات قتال غير قانونيه في مكان ما تحت
الارض انها بالفعل حلمت قتال تحت الارض
لكنها قانونيه بل وبتنظيم من السلطات فما
نشاهده بطوله للملاكمه لتكريم الجنود
الذين دافعوا عن مدينه خركاب ثاني اكبر
مدن اوكرانيا اقيمت في احدى محطات مترو
انفاق المدينه تحسبا لقصف روسي رياضيون من
الفريق الاولمبي الاوكراني انضموا الى
المباريات فيما توافد مئات السكان لمشاهده
الحدث الذي يعتبر الاول من نوعه منذ
الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
نكتفي بهذا القدر طبعا الزميله ميسون باتت
جاهزه لفتح المزيد من الملفات مساء الخير
ميسون مساء الخير راويه طبعا ملف
الانتخابات التركيه والجوله الاعاده يتصدر
مازال الاخبار فضلا عن الكثير من ميناء
الملفات منها موضوع الاستشفاء في السودان
موضوع سجل راشد الغنوشي بالاضافه الى جوله
زيلينسكي الاوروبيه وموضوع التسليح واتهام
واشنطن لطهران ببيع مسيرات انتحاريه الى
روسيا والكثير من الاخبار ارجو ان
تتابعينا تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات